this is a very serious picture it's
everyone there are viruses around that
have been around for thousands of years
they're not new viruses and I think it's
a general public we think they're new
they're not they're new to us because
we've gone to them they haven't come
knocking on our door they've been in the
rain forests they're in secret
mysterious parts of the planet where no
man has been or a woman has been before
and they've been living a life with
their hosts meaning the plant life or
the animal life that they live off of we
go in there and disturb it and suddenly
they need a new host they jump on the
back of a human being that's cutting
down the tree that human being gets on
an airplane and suddenly you've got
problems I know what I told her but now
I'm telling you we're facing a new
strain it spreads like the flu
impossible fine go to the hospital check
it out yourself go without a mask you'll
see more clearly what can happen is that
the virus can make a jump or it can go
from animal to human being and I know
that the top neurologists and
epidemiologists that I've read has said
that from here on and nothing will
surprise them that for every one we hear
about every horrible virus that we hear
about it suddenly decimates a village in
Africa within days that there are
thousands not really but you know with
the proliferation of information that
something as recently as the flu
epidemic which was I guess in 1918 and I
include myself would should he touch
them and that was we've we've forgotten
about it or it has no it has no weight
but that flu epidemic it's that it
happened today it would be probably the
great crisis of the last quarter century
that epidemic and we all we've heard
about you know in
the winds of the pool of the belly but
that epidemic killed 22 million people
in a series of a few months went around
the world and that was before jet travel
how do you research something like this
well I'll be working with Dustin Hoffman
just after the fall
I'm using everything in the arsenal we
have to work together Sam
you're really impressing me with your
knowledge of this is this something you
already knew where is this part of your
research for the role I knew nothing
about it
it's interesting it's just interesting
stuff because for those that don't
believe the Adam and Eve story the
theory is if this is that maybe bacteria
was the beginning of life that became a
one-celled creature or you know where is
a one-celled creature but the newer
theory is that virus was the beginning
of life a virus was before which came
before bacteria this much I can I can
give to the space of an hour a single
virus has invaded multiplied and killed
the cell in just over two hours its
offspring have invaded nearby cells here
and here continually multiplying but
virus of virus has no life of its own
it must connect itself to something and
once it does it has only one purpose and
that is to multiply multiply and it
forces everything else out and a theory
is is that that was indeed the beginning
of life the very thing which is now
threatening to Humble us and there's all
this information that he's come across
so and I find it as you're doing this
there's a lot of fear that you can feel
with this stuff because once it gets
loose its a baddie
[Music]